five minutes Melo understood so ugly
Carmelo seems oh my last friend and next
colors quite the opposite actually the
whole city cheers your name outside
these garden walls I saw what they did
to you more like what I did to them it's
not right
you're a legend I'm just an old enforcer
when I saw our front office treat you
well I do what I always does
I stand up for bass players especially
against a tongs who run is out these
days well I'm here to return the favor
now come on we don't have much time for
you mean what are you doing we're
getting you out of here we're waiting
guarantee the key toss it now huh
tokima stearic he had to go he had
family is he oh yeah
well then toss it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I've fit
[Music]
but do you have uh it's game dog its
erly
for sure but if the season ended today
we'd barely be in the AC do you want to
be in the AC I know that we don't want
that I don't want the IC no I don't want
that we are the places of Indiana we
don't settle for the AC ah
so Reggie Miller have settled for the
eighth season with Jermaine of Neil have
settled for the eighth see good Mark
Jackson or Rick Smith have settled for
the eighth seed hey rip Smith we are not
an eighth CD veteran are we will not be
a 7c team that I see is much better than
our record I see a fifth or sixth seed
see who will at best make it to the
second round but zombie fell further
right now our defense is 25th to leave
let's get that up to 15 and are often
its 20th let's is that up to maybe also
15 let's go out there and send those
systems but to Detroit it's regular
[Applause]
[Music]